question for you in your own businesses
though like now as you as you go about
run them
running them did you like did you take
any lessons away from your experience
with mark zuckerberg and working at
facebook that you
then apply to your own entrepreneurial
ventures
like were there any big aha moments any
big takeaways like oh that works on
facebook so i'm gonna use it over here
like kind of rip off and duplicate
yeah i think the the number one thing
that i still use this day 15 years later
uh is the singularity of his focus
one thing only he was exceptional at it
i mean i've worked i worked at microsoft
as an intern i met bill gates
uh i've met you know a lot of the idols
in the tech industry
and they're very one they're geniuses
they're above normal levels of
intelligence like you meet them and
you're like okay
you're thinking in things beyond me but
his focus on like
for example when i was working there i'm
a traditional entrepreneur in terms of i
like profit
it's crazy i know it's like women who
don't even know men anymore you know
uh and so i would go to mark and be like
hey here's how we can make money in the
business because i wanted to be
profitable
and it was it was a more silicon valley
business like clubhouse
is today which is we're gonna grow and
get super huge and then we'll
make money later
and that's fine that was just never
that's never my style but mark was
really
obsessive on uh hey i want to grow
the user base i'm just trying to grow so
if it does not grow the user base we do
not do it and so let me give you an
example with appsumo today um
and i'll tell you about my personal
stuff as well with appsumo we have a
revenue goal and that is
literally the main thing that matters in
the business and with youtube which is
what i do full time
our goal is 250 000 subscribers and that
is the only goal
that is our main kpi that we are focused
so uh
tightly on and i would definitely say
that was from mark which is you know you
meet a lot of entrepreneurs like yeah
well i'm trying to do this and
i'm trying to do that and you know my
goal's not clear and mark was just
very clear on where he was going
you